l'aube hayden souhaiterait-il retarder
le départ des troupes américaines en
afghanistan
c'est en tout cas ce que semble dire à
demi mots le nouveau locataire de la
maison blanche
pour lui la date du 1er mai 2021 convenu
entre talibans et l'ancienne
administration arrive un peu trop tout
cela peut arriver mais c'est difficile
je suis en train de prendre la décision
sur la date de leur départ
le fait est que l'accord conclu par
l'ancien président n'a pas été négocié
de manière très solide
un départ retardé des troupes
américaines ne serait pas vraiment une
manoeuvre apprécié des talibans ces
derniers espèrent que la date convenue
sera honoré sous peine de représailles
les américains devraient mettre fin à
leur occupation conformément à l'accord
de doha et retirer l'ensemble de leurs
troupes d'afghanistan d'ici au 1er mai
s'ils ne le font pas ils seront
responsables des conséquences
c'est donc dans ce contexte que
plusieurs acteurs de la paix en
afghanistan se rencontrent aujourd'hui à
moscou une réunion qui pourrait servir
de base avant une nouvelle entrevue au
mois d'avril en turquie pour tenter
d'apaiser les tensions
américains et russes se sont récemment
montrés favorables à la création d'un
gouvernement de transition incluant des
talibans proposition rejetée par le
gouvernement afghan
elle s'est donc un défi de taille qui
attend aujourd'hui les acteurs de cette
réunion à moscou pour tenter de ramener
la paix en afghanistan